god my girl didn't come to this show
holy [ __ ]
how you doing man i'm good did you know
you were going out
oh my god you guys [ __ ] to do tonight
what's going on
guy really did not do [ __ ] all day
i really disrespected his saturday
how do you know these guys
that's your family that's your wife you
know he's faithful
i have never seen a guy less interested
in looking attractive
in my life this guy loves you
he wants to repel every other woman that
comes up to him
wife you let him go out like this
is this normal behavior for him or is he
trying to get attention because it works
what's he has missy are you sick
no i mean seek punjabi that's why i'm
asking because you might have you know
you're punjabi but you're hindu where
are your parents did they not come with
you to america
they can't be okay with not the white
spouse i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about the outfit
you're okay with it though oh you're
very accepting how long you been married
a mo god damn i'm
this guy spent everything he had on his
indian wedding all the money is gone
it all went to horses and maybe an
elephant i hope you've got an elephant
with that [ __ ] budget
unbelievable it's a cut off t-shirt too
this guy
i am i have never seen brown white trash
in my life
[ __ ] believable what i'm looking at
what do you do for a living here so
you're a choreographer you think you'll
choreograph your outfit a little bit
better
you're putting [ __ ] together you know
that is crazy look at this minority he's
looking at you like what the [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here
this fine ass [ __ ]
ah is you see what you could have been
with
[Applause]
this [ __ ] is sex dude you see
this guy
holy [ __ ] i thought he had to be puerto
rican i was like there's no way
indian noodles is sexy
holy [ __ ] yo i can't [ __ ] believe it
even his leg cross is sexy
i'm so upset about this got a really
[ __ ]
digging on my insecurities looking to
this guy man i wish you were
[ __ ] dominican or something this is
unbelievable
i don't remember what i was talking
about i can't think straight with this
guy looking at me he got his chest out
putting your shirt dog stop sitting in
the front like this
bothering me
can't believe this [ __ ] gorgeous ass
dude is indian
man what do you do for a living i knew
it i knew it
i knew it i know it i knew he was
perfect
god my girl didn't come to this show
holy [ __ ]
just looking at what could have been he
from the same state as her and
everything
i've got to move on to the this indian
sorry buddy i got it
i can't handle it man this is
mesmerizing this guy
i'm honestly you gotta listen how y'all
married
my girlfriend yo marry an indian girl
man we can't lose you
you're too valuable you too valuable son
we need those genes in the community
i'm tired about this yo hey i'm sure
she's great have a second wife convert
to islam figure it out i don't know
we can't lose these genes this is normal
indian genes that's normal
you don't even have jeans that's how bad
indian jeans are
we can't lose this guy
[Applause]
guys thanks for watching the video if
you're a fan just hit subscribe stop
hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
[Music]
you